I know it's Austin you just have
microphones everywhere here
I'm gonna read for a little bit and then
take questions just like it every other
reading you've ever been to why is there
a glop of macaroni salad next to the
Japanese chicken in my plate lunch
because the ship Thaddeus left Boston
Harbor with the first boatload of New
England missionaries bound for Hawaii in
1819 that and it's Saturday rainbow
drivin only serves show you chicken four
days a week
a Banyan in Waikiki is a fine spot for a
sunburned tourist from New York City to
sit beneath and ponder the historical
implications of a lukewarm box of
takeout because none of us belong here
not me not the macaroni not the chicken
soaked in soy sauce
not even the tree like a lot of people
and things in these islands Banyan's our
imports from somewhere else in this case
India the Banyan's gray branches shoot
off slim sprouts that drip down and boar
slowly into the ground and take root
bulging into new connected trunks so as
to support more and more tendrils
leading to more and more trunks until
each tree becomes its own spooky little
forest there is a banyan shade in
Courthouse Square in the town of Lahaina
on Maui that was planted in 1873 to
commemorate the 50th anniversary of the
arrival of New England missionaries on
that island it was eight feet tall when
a missionary descendant planted it and
now it stands over 60 feet high with 12
trunks spanning more than 200 square
feet one time I was in the Lahaina
courthouse chatting with a woman who
worked there about the Banyan she told
me that the town gardeners put a lot of
effort into confining that tree within
the square because otherwise it would
keep on growing until its roots and
branches cracked the foundation
punctured the walls of all the nearby
buildings
finally toppling everything in its path
in fact the Banyan's tendency to crowd
out and destroy its neighbors has earned
it the pet name strangler fig here in
Waikiki the US Army Museum is hunkered
down in the midst of all the concrete
high-rise hotels and condominiums built
in the post 1959 statehood architectural
style I like to think of as a very Brady
Brutalism the park where my plate lunch
and I are sitting appears in an old
black-and-white photograph on display
there the picture was taken in the
summer of 1898 a few days after the sons
of missionaries who had dethroned the
Hawaiian Queen handed over Hawaii to the
United States the park is pitched with
the tents of the first New York
voluntary infantry the spanish-american
war had the soldier stopping off in this
suddenly American City enroute to the
Philippines to persuade the Filipino
people at gunpoint that self-government
really isn't for everyone they named
their encampment after the president who
dispatched them here Camp McKinley the
United States declared war on Spain in
April of 1898 by August the McKinley
administration had invaded the Spanish
colonies of Cuba Puerto Rico the
Philippines and Guam and annexed Hawaii
in this four-month orgy of imperialism
the United States became a world power
for the first time became what it is now
hurrah
for Hawaii Theodore Roosevelt wrote from
Cuba when he heard the news that the
u.s. annexed the islands he was in the
Caribbean with the Rough Riders licking
the Spanish at Santiago de Cuba one of
the end results of that conquest was
American control of Guantanamo Bay to
Roosevelt and his like-minded cronies in
the government and military the most
important objective of all the 1898
maneuvers was possession of far-flung
islands for naval bases and strategic
ports like Guantanamo and
loulou's Pearl Harbor he and his friends
had pined for these bases for years the
way a normal man envisions his dream
house all they ever wanted was a cozy
little global Empire with a few islands
here and there to park a fleet of
battleships that Japanese dive bombers
sank four of those battleships in Pearl
Harbor on December 7th 1941 is how I
ended up getting interested in Hawaii in
the first place a few years back the
purpose of my initial visit was a quick
jaunt to see the USS Arizona Memorial
the monument in the harbor perched above
the oily watery grave of the 1177
sailors who died on the ship that day
unlike the flip-flop boyars on my flight
to Honolulu I didn't come here for it
direct sunlight or fun I came to Hawaii
because it had been attacked after I
checked the Arizona off my to-do list I
still had some time to kill so I swung
by the Iolani Palace downtown curious to
take a look at the Victorian building my
guidebook billed as the only palace in
the United States a guide led my tour
group into the room where the white
businessmen and sugar planters who had
staged a coup d'etat against Queen
Liliuokalani in 1893 locked her up for
treason after her Royalists supporters
botched a counter-revolution
Liliuokalani wild away her imprisonment
in a room on the second floor of the
palace sewing a colorful quilt that is
on display there perhaps out of
melancholy or spite little flags of the
Kingdom of Hawaii stand guard around the
quilt center square in one corner she
embroidered a scene of a cartoonish man
struggling with an umbrella losing his
hat in the wind the guide chuckled over
this quaint bit of slapstick but I
wondered if it was the slide lament of a
woman whose crown has blown away and it
isn't coming back
I should mention that I was there in
December of 2003 the week before I
arrived in Honolulu
American soldiers captured Saddam
Hussein who was hiding in his grungy
spider hole outside of Tikrit so when I
was standing in the Victorian era cell
of a Polynesian Queen deposed by the
sons of chirchi New Englanders at that
exact moment the Iraqi dictator was
behind bars in a US military compound
being guarded by Pennsylvanians
not that the Queen a constitutional
monarch an accomplished musician famous
for writing the love song Aloha OE and
Saddam a mass murderer famous for
gassing 5,000 Kurds has much in common
and still there's an identifiable link
between the two overthrows an American
tendency to indulge in what trendy
government lingo at the time was calling
regime change when the Iolani Palace
tour guide mentioned the day the
Hawaiian flag on the palace grounds was
lowered and the American flag went up
she looked like she was going to cry I
couldn't help but picture that scene
from the TV news earlier in the year
when a US soldier celebrated the
invasion of Baghdad by climbing up a
statue of Saddam and covering his bronze
moustached face with the Stars and
Stripes a gesture that was both
unfortunate as PR and improper flag
etiquette it was telling to spend the
morning at a historic site like Pearl
Harbor one tattooed on the American
memory and the afternoon and another
historic site we have forgotten entirely
the groundswell of outrage over the
invasion of Iraq often cited the
pre-emptive war as a betrayal of
American ideals the subtext of the
dissent was this is not who we are but
not if you are standing where I was it
was hard to see the look in that palace
tour guides eyes when she talked about
the American flag flying over the palace
and not realized that ever since 1898
from time to time this is exactly who we
are and what's more Hawaii is just as
Theodore Roosevelt Circle predicted
crucial to the American Empire's
military presence
Pacific pearl harbor is still the
headquarters of US Pacific Command just
as it was for all three of America's
20th century Wars in the Pacific with
Japan North Korea and North Vietnam so I
started looking into Hawaii's bit-part
in the epoch of American and global
domination Americans and their children
spent the 78 years between the arrival
of Protestant missionaries in 1820 and
the American annexation in 1898
Americanizing Hawaii importing our
favorite religion capitalism and our
second favorite religion Christianity in
certain ways the Americanization of
Hawaii in the 19th century parallels the
Americanization of America just as their
Puritan forebears had set off on their
errand into the wilderness of New
England the New England missionary set
sail for the Sandwich Islands a place
they thought of as a spiritual
wilderness just as perhaps 9 out of 10
natives of the Americas were wiped out
by contact with European diseases so was
the Native Hawaiian population ravaged
by smallpox measles whooping cough and
venereal disease just as the Industrial
Revolution and the building of the
railroads brought in the huddled masses
of immigrants to the United States the
sugar plantations founded by the sons of
the missionaries required massive
imports of labor primarily from China
Japan Korea Portugal and the Philippines
transforming Hawaii into what it has
become a multi-ethnic miscellany in
which every race is a minority
hence the plate lunch two scoops of
Japanese style rice and one scoop of
macaroni salad seemingly airlifted from
some church potluck in anywhere USA are
served alongside a Polynesian or Asian
protein such as kalua pig chicken adobo
teriyaki beef or loco moco a hamburger
patty topped with gravy and a fried egg
a dish presumably invented to remedy
what has always been the hamburgers most
obvious defect not
egg sugar plantation workers used to
share food at lunchtime swapping tofu
and Chinese noodles for Korean spare
ribs and Portuguese bread that habit of
hodgepodge got passed down evolving into
the plate lunch now served at diners
drive-ins and lunch trucks throughout
the Hawaiian archipelago in 1961 the
lates a Jew a fugu established the
rainbow drive-in the joint on the edge
of Waikiki where I bought my plate lunch
if fuku had been an army cook with the
100th infantry battalion the mostly
Hawaii born japanese-american volunteer
soldiers in the 100th and the 442nd
Regimental Combat Team served as
segregated troops in Europe and North
Africa during World War two
becoming the most decorated unit in US
military history and earning the
nickname the Purple Heart battalion
their motto was remember Pearl Harbor
their argument was that they were
Americans not as the US government
classified them and their families enemy
aliens rainbow drive-ins menu offering
teriyaki hotdogs mahi-mahi and
Portuguese sausage reads like a list of
what America is supposed to be like a
neighborly mishmash Barack Obama the
Honolulu Board President of the United
States mentioned once on a trip home his
craving for plate lunch listing rainbow
drive-in as a possible stop a makes
sense considering that his cans and
mother met his Kenyan father at the
University of Hawaii and his mother's
remarriage blessed him with a half
Indonesian sister he's our first plate
lunch president
I suppose the double-sided way I see the
history of Hawaii as a painful tale of
native loss combined with an idealistic
multi-ethnic saga symbolized by mixed
plates in which soy sauce and mayonnaise
peacefully coexist and congeal tracks
with how I see the history of the United
States in general I'm the descendant of
Cherokees who were marched at gunpoint
by the US Army to Oklahoma on the Trail
of Tears yet I'm also and mostly the
descendant of European immigrants
notably Swedish peasants who left for
Kansas for the same reason Asian and
Portuguese plantation workers sailed to
Hawaii whenever I eat plate lunch I
always think back to the lore of my
Swedish great-grandfather's voyage
across the Atlantic supposedly the only
food he brought with him on the ship was
a big hunk of cheese then he befriended
a German in steerage whose only food was
a big hunk of sausage the Swede shared
his cheese with the German and the
German shared his sausage with the Swede
growing up I came to know America as two
places a rapacious country built on the
destruction of its original inhabitants
and a welcoming land of opportunity and
generosity built by people who shared
their sausage and their cheese in 1899
the British poet Rudyard Kipling
published his famous poem the white
man's burden about the new American
Empire of Island colonies of new cought
sullen people's four years earlier when
Kipling visited Washington DC for the
first time he met Theodore Roosevelt
Roosevelt dragged Kipling to the
Smithsonian to show off glass cases full
of American Indian artifacts Kipling
later wrote I never got over the wonder
of a people who having extirpated the
aboriginals of their continent more
completely than any modern race had ever
done honestly believed that they were a
godly little New England community
setting examples to brutal men
of the five countries the United States
invaded and/or acquired in 1898 Hawaii
is the only one that became a state that
said I have come to understand that even
though Hawaii has been a state since
1959 and in American territory since
1898 a small but defiant network of
native activists questioned the legality
of both developments and do not consider
themselves to be Americans at all which
is pretty easy to pick up on when
they're marching past you down the main
drag of Honolulu on the 50th anniversary
of statehood carrying picket signs that
say we are not Americans so oh thank you
so if you have questions a microphone
carrier will find you hi Sarah hi hi big
fan of yours obviously I know you
mentioned your nephew Oh and a lot in
your novel in your book says Ryan how is
he doing and how old is he now
um Owen my nephew is almost 11 how is he
doing you know he I don't know I haven't
seen him in a while I did just see him I
do like to travel with him I saw him a
few weeks ago we went to some Mayan
ruins in Mexico and Guatemala and I
don't know he's quite a budding
wordsmith I mean he I asked if he could
sit next to me on the plane home I was
like I don't know are you gonna be a
total pill it was like maybe only a
chewable
being there I'm not curious how you go
about doing your research like what is
your process from start to finish my
what is my process from start to finish
well let's see um you know I I read a I
read a bunch of books first a lot of you
know I read some of the official
histories then I read some you know
primary documents or diaries memoirs
that kind of thing I had a lot of
missionary memoirs this time lucky me
and and you know official buyer II but
biographies of all the you know players
and then and then I just start going and
doing reporting trips where in this case
I went to back and forth from my home in
New York City to the islands I think
seven or eight times and would stay
sometimes for a week sometimes for
several weeks where I would you know
rent an apartment including one in the
building that Jack Lord stands on top of
in the opening credits of Hawaii five-o
and then I spent on this one I spent a
lot of time in archives in Honolulu the
mission houses which houses the
missionary Papers reading all of their
letters and diaries and then the State
Archives of Hawaii which has a lot of
the government papers and the monarchy
papers and the Bishop Museum archives
and you know they have various treasures
and artifacts and also you know just
reading a lot of old newspapers on
microfilm the whaling newspaper that
kind of stuff and then also going to
historic sites and and interviewing
curators and tour guides and and then
there I did some other interviews with
them various locals you know some of
them independence activists you know one
of one of them my interviews with a
woman who became a good friend of mine
who was on a mission
a descendant that kind of thing yes oh
oh sorry oh sorry microphones hi Sarah I
was curious to know if you saw the
annexation of Hawaii as maybe having
some sort of modern ripple effect in
some way causing the birther movement I
don't I mean correct me if I'm wrong but
I I'm you know the birthers not a word I
enjoy saying because I like English I
don't know that they're entirely up to
speed on the history of Hawaii in the
1890s I believe their focus and concerns
are more prompted by anger at who the
president is I mean trying to find ways
to you know not making me the president
unless I'm wrong about that so I don't
really think there's too much I mean I
guess the two things are vaguely length
in that if the United States had never
annexed Hawaii a person born in Honolulu
would not be eligible to be president
and therefore would not garner such you
know loathing as the current one but uh
no I don't I don't think they're that
linked i but I'm not sure yeah you pick
Oh
my grace you know I drove three and a
half hours it'd be here with you thank
you I'm from the radio radio yeah sir Lu
Olo syrup in Wow to my heart
and we're also 38 years old so there's a
connection anyways since you've been on
our TV shows like the last one was David
Letterman is he like or is he like
how good I mean you know David Letterman
any of them like even Colbert well there
what am I supposed to say I think David
Letterman you know it's kind of a
youthful hero of mine and he's actually
a real reader who has always been
nothing but nice to me and my books so I
have nothing but kind thoughts for the
man which is makes a terrible story oh
he's very nice to me and helps me sell
my books it's a terrible story but you
know I write nonfiction you gotta tell
the truth but thanks for driving I had
the rest of you probably like rode your
hippy bikes here
so when you when you when you're coming
up with an idea for the next thing that
you want to work on you come up with a
bunch of ideas and then one really
sticks with you or are you sitting
around one day and you're like yeah
that's it yep I mean it's different
every time
but like I don't have my next idea so
sure I have a million ideas every day
almost all of them lame at this point
but uh it's art like kind of know it
when you see it like the last book my
one about the Puritans I started I mean
I'd always wanted to write about the
Puritans I mean who doesn't because I
love John Winthrop sermon and what a
little Christian charity specifically
and I had been thinking about them for a
while but then I really started writing
that book after Ronald Reagan's funeral
and that that sermon was read at his
funeral and you know that sermon because
of presence because it's the sermon
where we get the image of New England
and later America as a city upon a hill
and it's a sermon about charity and
generosity and and that it was so
closely associated with President Reagan
a president whose administration was not
about charity and generosity it was in
fact about gutting every social program
designed to help one's fellow man so
that was just a little little kick I
needed you know to get cracking I
thought it was a good time to revisit
that speech just because you know when
threw up in that sermon because it is
about charity and generosity he he says
you know we shall be as a city upon a
hill and to him that was two-sided like
yes it could turn out the way we talked
about that image now that you know this
place eventually the United States then
just New England would be as a city
funny health to be a beacon of hope and
light and you know to the world but uh
Winthrop also meant it two ways the
secondly being we
could fail and everyone can see our
failure you know we'll be up there and
everyone will have a great view of our
failure and he defined that failure as
some colonists failure to take care of
one another so that's why that one yes
Sara I noticed your food plates you
didn't say anything about poi hi and
does Jim Nabors still have his show over
there I don't know what's been happening
with Jim Nabors in the last 40 years
what about poi poi is still you know a
very prized food amongst the Hawaiians
it's not just a staple food it's a it's
a it's an object of almost religious
devotion it's the you know mashed taro
root I personally let's say I haven't
craved it for a while since I left
Hawaii but I mean it I mean there is a
whole story there you know one of the
one of them people I interviewed a
doctor whose grandmother said worked for
the last queen of Hawaii he he walked me
through the the creation myth I mean I
always sat down to interview him and I
asked him a question about the overthrow
of the Queen in 1893 and he answered by
going back to the beginning of time but
you can imagine it was a very long
interview and during that during when he
was talking about the beginning of time
you know he talked about you know the
earth-mother mating with the sky father
and all that in the a.m. when the object
of the union was the stillborn and when
that child was buried up sprouted the
first taro plant and then the the next
sibling was the first human and so the
the people saw the taro plant and
an older sibling and the the number one
sibling and the number one siblings job
is to take care of all the younger
siblings so the taro is the staple food
and it's not just you know like what a
cheese steak is in Philly it's it's um
it's a member of the family kind of so
it's been very cherished for very long
but then you know a lot of the it's it's
um it's a rare plant it has been for the
last you know century or so just because
so much of the land that used to be used
to grow the taro got turned into sugar
plantations hello I I know I don't like
these things oh my goodness okay all
right sorry can I sing I'm kidding all
right um I know this is uh I'd say who's
your favorite author parts but yes I
mean curious I don't really have one
favorite author there are two that I
return to again and again when I'm
writing like if I'm stuck and I just
want to you know revive myself and not
just give up and you know eat cereal in
front of television or something and
that what one of them is moby moby dick
I'll always you know just crack it open
at random and read for a little bit and
and it's language is so weird and the
story is so strange and it's just it
just reminds me of I mean it's just a
jam-packed a little book you know and it
it's like cold water splashing at my
face just because it reminds me of what
a book can be but it's so different from
the way I think and speak and write that
it doesn't you know it doesn't bleed
into my storytelling and the other is
Charles Adams the cartoonist I have a
big stack of old Charles Adams books of
cartoon collections and I just flipped
through the
and he's so also just so delightful and
strange and funny there's something that
it's like those two like it's just like
a can flick a switch in me you know and
I also wanted to ask and I'm doing a lot
of research on my family and the history
and I'm part Cherokee um the rest brace
logic but are you thinking about a book
but I mean there's so many books on you
know the well I'm not acidic because
there's not enough there's not enough
not the way that Congress is going right
now so but if he thought about the
Cherokee oh um I did write one very long
essay about the Trail of Tears that's in
one of my essay collections so I don't I
doubt I would revisit that but there is
a little bit you know I do revisit some
of the history of that tribe in this
Hawaii book just because it's the same
organization in Boston the the American
Board of Commissioners for foreign
missions who they're the the group that
sent the missionaries to Hawaii there
are also the group that sent
missionaries to the Cherokee Nation and
Christianized westernized the Cherokee
and you know that same group started
this school up in Connecticut for
heathen youths where all of these ships
New England ships you know and the China
trade were coming back with all these
kids from all over the world
and they some of them were put in this
school including the boy who is
basically the first Hawaiian Christian
and and two of the two of the Cherokee
men who they studied there as boys and
they were a couple of the ones who
signed that treaty against the will of
the rest of the tribe that gave the US
government permission sort of legally to
start the Trail of Tears so there's a
there is a real a concrete connection
but that group of missionaries really
got around
here's one I don't know hi hi I also
drove three and a half hours but from
Corpus but - do you have any words
obviously libraries have been important
or I would assume so in your research
and as a former librarian because budget
cuts are awesome do you have any words
maybe to advocate to any any you know
just telling how important libraries
have been to your process Oh in case
Texas legislators are watching c-span at
7:00 a.m. on a Sunday mornings I mean
not gonna sit I'm not gonna reinvent the
wheel yes libraries have been very
important to me that's where the books
are I mean when I was little I spent the
first eleven years of my life in a tiny
tiny tiny town in Oklahoma that had no
library and like at the school there was
one shelf that had some books on it and
you could take those home but you know
you run through those books pretty quick
and when I was 11 years old my family
moved to a college town in Montana that
had more than one library you know and
that first summer my sister I mean and
sidewalks they had sidewalks also sweep
and so and we like to roller skate and
so that first summer we spent I mean
moving from Oklahoma to Montana probably
it just it sounds like one you know
sticks to another but it was a college
town and to us it was basically like we
had moved to Paris and that first
magical summer we had rollerskates and
the sidewalks and we would roller skate
to the library every day you know and we
just thought we had moved to
civilization no offense Oklahoma
you know I would when I was in high
school I I would skip school a lot I
would skip the that doesn't sound good
stay in school kids better I would skip
school and you go to the library you
know so I mean library's not just like
for my work as a writer obviously I mean
in this book I was helped tremendously
by archivists and librarians you know at
the those institutions I mentioned in
Hawaii I mean some of that would be
impossible without them you know the you
know I can't tell you what you can learn
from microfilm of old newspapers and I
mean and not all of that or even much of
it it has been digitized and is
available you know widely so I mean I I
can't even I can't imagine
I mean libraries are just so crucial and
vital and I don't even know how to talk
about life without them you know it's
like oh there aren't gonna be any more
eggs anymore you know like what so I
don't yeah I wish I had some something
super zippy to say about it but I mean I
do think it's um they're so important
and I mean you don't know how great a
library is unless you were born into a
town that doesn't have one let's put it
that way sure
we lived in Hawaii years ago and I we
knew the history and all that but it is
interesting how the natives are
conflicted about being Americans being
Hawaiians and it is a different state to
live in it is like I said interesting
how they don't always consider
themselves as part of the United States
but it got to be very aggravating to
hear people come over and visit or go
over and visit and say well back in the
States
we're back in the US and we would say
you are in the US or we would go back to
visit and hear people say well how now
that you're back in the u.s. I would say
we are living in the u.s. we're in
Hawaii
well Hawaii is not really a state and
things like that and it's what has been
since I could remember back in 1959 and
I guess you heard a lot you heard that
well I watched um I think those shows
Jack Paar did in Hawaii right I think
it's right after statehood and he does
um ask this crowd of people what he what
do you think of the United States and
they all yell but you're in it you know
but uh I mean I think some of that
dislocation and I think some of that is
just a byproduct of what happens when
you know one country on a continent
you know colonizes an island thousands
of miles from its Shore in some ways
yeah I mean it's so it's in some ways
it's it's a completely American place to
me just because it's so militaristic
there are military bases and training
grounds everywhere it's exceedingly
religious there's a lot of really crummy
commercial architecture
which is a you know a bit of a specialty
in this country there there are so many
things about it I mean especially and
then you have all those hotels and
resorts with all the hotels and there
and the resorts and then all the
military bases it's you know there's a
writer I really like named Steve
Erickson who once wrote that the two
great contributions of the American
civilization are annihilation and fun he
was writing that about Las Vegas and a
piece about you know the all the old
nuclear tests that we're done in the
Nevada desert but that I think that
metric applies to Hawaii as well I mean
but then on the other hand you know it
is there it is still so much so often
the the sovereign independent country at
once was you know the language the even
you know English speakers people who
would say they don't speak Hawaiian
hoin words are peppered into normal talk
if you were gonna ask directions from
someone they would tell you to go Malka
or Makai that means you know mauka
toward the mountains or Makai toward the
ocean and there's a I mean it is such a
singular place and it still has so many
vestiges of you know it's singular
culture that it is kind of lost in a way
you know that's maybe why Lost was
filmed there like I have I have a friend
who I was he's a teacher and I was
speaking to him and some of his
colleagues and I was talking about some
King and I was butchering his name and
the pronunciation and I made some I just
said I hate saying Hawaiian words in
front of Hawaiians and my friend was
driving me home later and he said it's
funny you called us wines cuz I don't
think of myself as a Hawaiian and I said
what are you talking about you were born
here you're you live here he went to
high school here and he just said I know
but you know my family his ancestors
came from Japan and Germany and he just
I don't know and compared to it's like
that in New York where I live you know
it's the
very disparate place with all these
people from all over the world and all
this different kind of food and but but
I'm but everyone who's been there awhile
considers themselves New Yorkers it
doesn't matter where you're from or
where your ancestors are born or what
color your skin is or whatever it's just
all one big jumble and like fairly
happily so so there is something there
is this kind of lost quality about
Hawaii and and the identity of the place
and the people and that I think is is
you know a result of this kind of I
guess it's sort of kind of
Americanization and and what happened
when the missionary offspring overthrew
the Hawaiian queen in 1893 was kind of a
severing from the Hawaiian past you know
one of the other things she did when she
was locked up in that in her cell was
she translated the the creation myth
which is a genealogy that that tells the
story of Hawaii from the beginning of
time from you know the slime that
created the earth up through her own
ancestors and I think one reason she did
that after her overthrow is she's she's
thinking about that and that long long
long eons of Hawaiian past that has just
been you know you know severed and I
think they're still you know it's like
what is that called when I'm you have
something is amputated the law is it
lost limb syndrome phantom limb thank
you I think there still there's always
going to be that there I mean it makes
it a very fascinating place for that
reason you know
hi buck ideas where I came up with the
idea for my book on presidential
assassinations I don't know I don't I
don't remember I think I was writing a
lot about President Lincoln and it must
have just occurred to me in some of my
lincoln research i don't have a snappy
story i find your style really dry and
funny so i was wondering if you ever
entertained the idea of branching out
into fiction because you mentioned that
no and that question which comes up a
lot is such an insult to nonfiction i
just because something is true no I know
I'm not a liar there are tons of other
liars whose books you're welcome to buy
here
I mean the thing I love about nonfiction
is it does not have to seem plausible
you know like not nonfiction it's about
things like like that can't be true but
it is you know action you have to write
these stories that seem like they could
have happened to people who might exist
but you don't have to do that when
you're writing about a weirdo like
Abraham Lincoln or you know I mean they
even in this Hawaiian story one thing
that that's so that happens is as the
first missionaries are leaving Boston
Harbor while they're on route to you
know come and and Christianize the
Hawaiians well while they're on the way
while they're on the water the new
Hawaiian King decides to abolish the old
religion if you put that in one of your
fiction type stories that's just gonna
seem like you know like no like that's
too easy
but then the missionaries show up and
they get the news oh guess what the old
religion has been you know band and
outlawed and there's nothing to replace
it and here we just sailed into the
spiritual vacuum to you know sell our
Christian wares and they I mean to them
it would just seemed like God was on
their side and you know it's a gift from
God but if you put that in a made-up
story I mean that just doesn't that just
wouldn't work because it just is
unbelievable or like you know that and
about this that story of how John Adams
and Thomas Jefferson died on the same
day and it's the 50th anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence it's July
4th 1826 if you put that in a novel that
would be so laughable
but you know it's fact and therefore it
can be as you know implausible as
possible
anyway fiction I'm I know I'm a groupie
and I pre-order everything you write
just as soon as I hear it's coming out
thank you very much
however this one winning where's this
going when it came out with the title
and familiar fishes uh-huh I had no idea
what you were going to be writing about
mmm and it's just like where did I hate
subtitles go on what inspired you to use
that title oh it is it's it's a
quotation from from a letter written by
one of the first Hawaiian writers his
name is David Malo and he was almost 30
years old when the first missionaries
arrived on Maui the island where he
lived at the time and they taught him
how to read and write Hawaii he was well
schools in the Hawaiian oral tradition
but the missionaries from New England
had to invent a written language for
Hawaiian so they taught they taught him
and some other people to read in fact
pretty much the entirety of the Hawaiian
population within a generation and
within a few years he was writing his
book Hawaiian antiquities which is a
compendium of sort of knowledge on the
classical Hawaiian culture that was
dying away thanks to the coming of the
Westerners he and it's a very it's a
very beautiful very useful book but and
he became he was very he was under the
influence of these New Englanders he
learned to read write he became a
teacher and a minister and but being a
writer which is to say grumpy and full
of misgivings as he saw you know as the
years wore on and he saw more and more
white people kind of drowning his
homeland and not
the missionaries you know Maui where he
lived was a was one of the stopping
points for whalers during the Golden Age
of whaling so there would be you know
there are hundreds of whaling ships
stopping in Hawaiian ports and at the
same time so as he saw all of these
white people coming in moving in you
know dropping by sailors on leave there
and probably not the ones to make the
best impression he wrote this really sad
letter to these native friends where he
says when a something like I'll try to
get it right when a big wave comes in
large when a large and unfamiliar fishes
come from the dark ocean and they see
the small fishes of the shallows and
they will eat them up and then he says
the big men from the important countries
come here and see that our people are
small they will devour us so it was kind
of prophetic but I also like just
pulling unfamiliar fishes out of that
just because um my book is about these
Americans and the Americans who came to
Hawaii in that time in the nineteenth
century they're not they're not like
regular Joe Americans you know you got
your bible-thumping killjoys you got
your sailors on leave and then a bunch
of you know capitalists and con men and
other kind of dreamers so the these
they're something about just pulling
that out unfamiliar fish its kind of
captured that it's about these kind of
singular types who who ended up their
time for one more question
Sara your first book was a media study
for my listeners point of view have you
thought about doing one now that you've
been on the other side with NPR your
television appearances oh you want to
read a diary of me going like going on
book tour and talking to talking to
interviewers ya know that hadn't
occurred to me
I will say that that year I that was my
first book listening to the radio for a
year that was a prison sentence and I
have you know it's been more than a
decade that I was you know let out on
Pearl so no I mean the one thing about
that forum it was it was you know I had
to listen to the radio every day and I
don't know if you ever listen to the
radio but it was kind of trying as a
project but I do think there is
something in that form that definitely
captured the time you know the year I
listened was 1995 and I mean I don't
really listen to a lot of different
kinds of radio so much anymore but at
the time I can't imagine that it's
gotten more violent the talk you know
like when I turned on the radio I think
maybe on the first day this was right
before Oklahoma City before you know
before especially with the right-wing
talk radio that people started wondering
hey maybe he shouldn't talk like that
all the time you know and the reason I
wrote it was because I because of the
1994 congressional elections and the
freshman congressman when the
Republicans took over the Congress
called themselves the ditto head caucus
and I thought radio I was having this
huge impact on the country and I was
kind of unaware of that that side of it
but you know I would hear before
Oklahoma City you know I heard maybe on
the first day a kid with a paper route
calling in a talk show saying there's
this other kid trying to horn in on my
paper route and and the host would say
oh you need to get a gun I mean they
said it in jest you know and then I
remember maybe a week into it I was
visiting my parents in Montana and
there's this big snowstorm there was so
much snow that they that the streets
weren't plowed yet and I went
cross-country skiing in the middle of
the night it was so fluffy and white and
wonderful and you know and then I came
back and turned on the radio and there
was some person saying that you could
solve the problem of the welfare mother
and the illegal immigrants by giving
them welfare mothers jobs by posting
them at the border to gun down all the
illegal immigrants like when I say it
was a prison sentence I'm saying it's
not like oh it was really hard having to
hear Slayer songs all day long it was
like it was very dark and violent and
terrible things I had to listen to you
know that so I don't yeah I mean and I
think we forget that we forget that or I
mean I don't know I would like to forget
it but I can't and then after you know
Oklahoma City when that happened there
was something President Clinton said
even let's stick with me when that
happened he said you know if there's
talk of hate stand up and talk against
it and that was something that was nice
to hear after you know a few months of
listening to violent calls to murder in
between commercials so I don't see
recreating that experience lovely as it
was but I did I mean it was I I didn't
you know it was my first book and I
learned a lot by writing and publishing
it and it's a very like dark and I think
kind of angry raw book but I I think
that comes from what I had to listen to
maybe we can have one more question just
and could it maybe be slightly more
hopeful that's not from your question
that's me and the darkness I'll have to
work on hopeful I think now I was
curious too do you see a parallel
between the the missionary effort that
you write about in here and the Dulles
brothers who enjoyed life in the 50s and
I don't know who the Dulles brothers are
John Foster Dulles oh yeah I've been to
that Airport
who brought us the overthrow Mosaddegh
and they had it does seem to be a habit
of ours you know we don't like the guy
running Guatemala I know what we can do
or you know we don't like the guy
running Iran I mean these things do kind
of or you know the we don't like the guy
running Cuba that kind of thing I mean
the thing it's one thing for a
government to want to hope for foreign
leaders who would perhaps if not acting
our interest at least you know not you
know but uh the thing about the United
States is at our founding and in the
Declaration of Independence you know
defines our belief our theory of
government is that it should be based on
the consent of the governed so by
definition the idea that Americans would
go abroad and try and like monkey with
other country's rulers is a
contradiction you know it is a best
hypocritical is that what you're talking
about well the thing about the
difference with Hawaii is the
missionaries the original missionaries
the ones who came in the 1820s and 30s
they weren't the ones who overthrow the
Queen it's their children the ones who
were born in Hawaii who most of them
attended the school founded by the
missionaries to educate missionary
children that's the school our president
went to it's those it's those children
the Hawaii born Hawaiians or there were
Hawaiian subjects who overthrow the
Queen and to them religion played very
little rolled the Queen was a more
devout Christian than any of those guys
ever were so at the original
missionaries in Hawaii had as their men
they were supposed to westernize and
civilize the Hawaiians as best they
could but they also had strict
instructions not to mess with the
government and not get involved with
political affairs because political
affairs are of this
earth and they were to be concerned with
getting as many Hawaiian into the
kingdom of heaven as possible and most
of them really stuck to that a few of
them did quit the mission to go on and
work for the Hawaiian government but
they they had to quit their jobs as
missionaries to do that you know there
was one ex missionary who helped with
the framing of a new constitution when
the Hawaiian King made Hawaii into a
constitutional monarchy there was one
missionary who quit the the mission to
work in the judiciary because he
objected to the fact that the
headquarters back in Boston was taking
donations from slave states this was
before the Civil War so the actual the
actual missionaries did more or less
stick to their plan partly because they
just didn't have time to do anything
else these were incredibly burdened
overloaded people who they had I mean
look at what they did they had so they
wanted to they wanted to make everyone
Christians and because they're
protestant that means they need everyone
to be reading their Bibles so they have
to a invent the written language then be
translate the Bible and because they're
persnickety seminary educated New
Englanders they translate the Bible from
Greek and Hebrew into Hawaiian and they
have to publish that then they have to
teach everyone to read and and and run
the schools and preach their sermons and
you know and because it's a monarchy
they have all have other commands and
demands the aristocrats place on them
the the missionary wives were always
having to drop everything and and so new
dresses for the queens and the and the
chiefly women I mean and there's just so
much new and they had to you know build
their houses and build their churches
they were so overworked and overburdened
that they really didn't have time to you
know do any coup d'etat team but their
children their children you know their
children did and they and religion
really had very little to do with it
because as like Sandford old the man
after the overthrow who becomes the the
president of the Republic of Hawaii he
and the Queen you know they went to the
same
Church and he taught Sunday school and
she led the choir you know she was um
she was a solid Christian and in fact in
her book her memoir which I recommend
it's called Hawaii story by Hawaii's
Queen she she has she's she writes the
book it's her story but it's also she's
publishing it in 1898 to argue against
annexation and she uses two arguments
against annexation well several but two
of them think this this doesn't seem
Christian and I basically implies God
will smite us if we do this to her
little country and the other one is that
it doesn't seem in keeping with you know
the demands of democratic republican
government so there's that I would like
to thank you all for coming thanks
Austin